[Music]
it was mr. ha
whoa you want oh we said some Johnny
takes me back to dancing can Romancing
have you ever won on day two well right
there
we're gonna need a profile photo don't
worry if you take you know no wall for
someone to respond Wow look looks like
the old gal still got it
[Music]
I've been thinking for many many years
about the notion of making a music
driven film where music was part of the
narrative I shared these ideas with
Garth the director over tea in London
and he lit up my next show is going to
be drumroll please a singing competition
it's one of those ideas you in a story
to that you could instantly see the
potential for in every direction what I
saw in Buster as a producer he began to
see in Buster as a writer director I
could take a lot of characters and I
could put them all through this
extraordinary process of trying to you
know you make their dreams come true
through music and music is such a
powerful way to to tell so it makes him
examining so Universal what did you
think
he said $100,000 hunch
Taine's true entertaining story among
all these stars one performer really
Sparkle junker ah yes thanks it's about
the cloudless nature piggy power this is
supreme confidence killer dance moves
and fabulous outfit culture has emerged
as the clear crowd favorite is unbridled
talent let the music take control of
your party pop and pure animal magnetism
electrifies this day and he never ceases
to amaze with a one question on
everyone's mind
oh let's take off these pounds it allows
him what will she do next
gunther pulls out all the stops on sings
true entertaining story
[Music]
but our face doesn't need to be so sad
it just needs to be lost because he
comes from some experience with live
action
so animation has been all very new to
him but he's the most enthusiastic
learner the face kind of moved as
instead of thoughts going through his
head I thought yeah I'll be fine yeah
I've done live action movies and loads
of things like that'll be fine
there was totally different and it's
like work on a giant like production
light moving your movie from department
to Department on ously with the script
but then very quickly we started to
design the character in the world there
are a lot of great things about making a
movie with illumination but one of the
best ones is what we Derek Aeon because
instantly your world is unique
we wanted it to be beautiful and we
wanted it to be a world that you know
you could really to quote Chris Millard
Andric crawl into
we went for a california-style digit but
instead of somewhere I think it's kind
of a match between San Francisco Los
Angeles with some Miami the color scheme
thrown in there just to sort of keep it
delicious we had those influences
mint-infused all of that into our set
designs